some of you may know who Deadpool is but
how much do you really know before you
see his big screen live-action adventure
here's 13 things you ought to know why
13 because 14 would be a silly number
for a list number 13 if most of your
Deadpool knowledge is from x-men origins
Wolverine you need to forget everything
you've seen every thing that never
happened that was not number 12
when Deadpool debuted he seemed very
similar to Deathstroke at DC Comics as a
joke the creator's gave him the name
Wade Wilson similar to Slade Wilson they
even sort of fought in a Superman Batman
comic number 11 Wade Wilson was dying of
cancer after going through an experiment
he gained a super healing factor but
this made his normal and cancerous cells
unable to die giving him a scarred
appearance he looks like a topographical
map of Utah exactly number 10 Wade
Wilson took the name Deadpool during the
time he was being experimented on the
guards had a Deadpool and gambled on
which test subject would die next number
9 Deadpool is a character that breaks
the fourth wall in the comics he first
broke the fourth wall in 1999 s Deadpool
number 28
when bullseye asked him how long it had
been since they last saw each other
Deadpool replied issue 16 we will likely
see some fourth wall breaking in the
movie
did I leave to stove on number eight
Deadpool is known as the Merc with the
mouth he talks a lot a good example is
when he was hard up for money and
applied to be a herald for the planet
devouring being known as Galactus
Deadpool talks so much Galactus had to
dismiss him before he had a chance to
get paid
number seven in the movie Wade has a
girlfriend in the comics Vanessa
Carlysle was a shape-shifting mutant
known as copycat she met and fell in
love with Wade who left her when he
thought he was dying of cancer she was
first introduced posing as a mutant
Domino number six weasel is Deadpool's
friend and sidekick
his real name is jackhammer they first
kind of met when deadpool accidentally
teleported back in time to Jack's
highschool days
Deadpool knew weasel could help him
repair his teleportation belt so
disguised as Peter Parker
he cost weasel a job with Norman Osborn
by telling him weasel was on drugs this
led to weasel turning to a life of crime
the two later formed a working
relationship with weasel making weapons
and gadgets for deadpool number 5
one day weasel did the unthinkable and
teleported to Deadpool's home in San
Francisco he discovered Deadpool's
prisoner / housekeeper / mother figure
blind l Deadpool would sometimes keep
her in a small room called a box filled
with sharp objects although he never
kept the door locked figuring she
wouldn't try to escape they had a weird
relationship and often played pranks on
each other with blind L usually
outwitting Deadpool eventually he gave
her her freedom but she refused knowing
she was a good influence on him she has
popped up again from time to time in the
comics number 4 Deadpool is in love with
death during the time he was being
experimented on he first saw death and
was surprised a grim reaper would be
drop-dead gorgeous
she's frequently come into his life but
things just don't quite work out for
them number 3 Deadpool's healing factor
lets him regenerate and survive body
parts being cut off after a stalker
collected severed Deadpool parts they
reformed as evil Deadpool Deadpool and
evil Deadpool ended up fighting of
course number 2
Deadpool's greatest weakness is kittens
when taking a gig with the evil Roxxon
corporation a town decided to fight back
because their water supply had been
poisoned
a crazy cat lady attacked Deadpool with
cats Deadpool was helpless
number 1 Deadpool doesn't really like
chimichangas he just really likes saying
to word it is possible he's come around
since he has been seen eating them from
time to time time to make the chinny
[ __ ] chunga's there are some other
facts you might be interested in like
Deadpool discovered he had a daughter he
married a queen of the undead who was
supposed to marry Dracula and he was
also tricked into killing his parents
but he's not aware of this so let's just
keep that between us if you're craving
more Deadpool pick up some comics read
them just be sure to avoid that other
movie that absolutely did not feature
Deadpool at all
you